Well, hold on.
Oh, there we go.
Hello, hello, hello.
My, my boo.
Hi,
everybody.
Hi, hi, hi.
I was just making sure.
No.
I have to restart my game.
I have to restart it.
Hold on.
Okay, wait.
It was fine until like now.
Or I had it open.
Okay, wait.
Hold on.
uh hello everybody welcome in yeah the double cursor it's
doing it again it's doing it again okay wait uh uh yeah uh i
do this okay so basically i have like a system i have to do
i have to start the game oh wait a second let me see if it
lags on my end
it lags on my end if it doesn't if it does oh oh it's not
lagging never mind i don't have to do anything whoa
welcome back everybody to bioshock bioshock wow
I'm really tired.
Guys, I'm so sleepy.
I'm so eppy slipper.
Oh, I can't say that in front of Vicky.
It's your birthday!
Sparky, happy birthday!
Thank you so much for that!
Hakusuma, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
I hear big daddy.
Welcome to the Circus of Value.
I'll be honest.
Oh gosh, it's been so long since I played this game.
And I'm so like brain dead right now.
I'm like, do I remember how to play this game?
So let's take a second.
Let's take a second to remember how things are.
So what?
Let's do a recap.
Let's take a second to remember how to play the game.
oh there is no running that's right there is just walking
can will they let me back in here no they hate me actually
um okay previously on bio shock would you kindly take a
second no rush to finish today take your time relearning
honestly yeah i did say the next time i played this i wanted
to um finish it so i was really determined about it you got
this meat though it's all shooting eating and most
importantly pipes i can't wait for pipes oh i'm single thank
you so much for the aqua super gonna keep the supas coming
because it's also my birthday happy birthday thank you
everyone is making so cute for the watch thank you no you
guys i don't why do you send aqua supas on your birthdays!
You should be using the money to get something delicious and
fun for yourself!
I always feel so bad.
But thank you.
Happy birthday!
Looks like you got a few fools in the chat today yeah
including you oh man um did you guys see my oh i have an
announcement which is my newest voice pack voice voice packs
a voice pack containing multiple voices hope you're doing
well oh brandon good luck good luck with everything the one
who recently started watching it was cool to see a previous
model and original outro is it oh thank you i wouldn't say
it was like my complete outro but just something that i
would do at the end of stream yeah we spend money on things
we like and we like binto the link doesn't work i'll get it
i'll get it probably the site crashed probably so many
people are like you know thank you for the voice pack miss
sussie mcsusserson of course um once once uh once this once
the site gets fixed i'll let you guys know just be patient
but of course there there is a my voice pack you can listen
to it on twitter i might upload it here too because it's
kind of silly
um if it wasn't a dot gov domain i would have sniped the
domain that's exactly why it's a domain i was like hmm what
can i do to make it so that people can't buy this domain so
that they could have it lead to goatsy or something that
would be so embarrassing buy my voice pack and then it's
goatsy that's not an april fools i mean it is but nobody
wants that
Nobody would want that.
Don't teach the kids what goats is.
We need to bring back the ancient text.
What are you talking about?
Would be funny.
It'd be kind of funny.
It would be horrible and kind of funny.
But, you know, Rickrolls are too tame, right?
when you really we got to put the freak back and freak
phantom i would laugh funny in a messed up way would be i
would feel really terrible i'm not gonna lie i would feel i
would feel absolutely horrible
sorry and before the government registers the url for real
that sounds cute i love goats Me too.
I'm mobile because computer broke, but yay, Bioshock!
Oh no, why is it broke?
Bring back Meat Spin.
Oh, geez.
Really?
Ancient Trauma Recall.
Honestly, I didn't even think of that thing.
Meat Spin forever.
I don't want to think about it, actually.
Let's ignore it.
Let's forget this conversation is happening.
April Fools, everybody.
April Fools.
Mint Spin.
Yeah, I'm just spinning around.
I'm like, wee, wee.
But I did say last time I played Bioshock, which was a
really long time.
ago at this point it was like a month ago or something um
that i next time i played it apparently according to some
people i only have like they were like oh five six hours if
i do a longer stream i'd be able to get through it most
likely and i was so i was so ready i was like oh my gosh i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna i'm gonna beat bioshock also because
i'm so I'm also kind of like sick of I'm sick of uh what's
the word um having to deal with the tech issues of the game
I'm sick of having to deal with the tech issues of the game
so I'm like okay well this is fine I will just beat it and
get it done with um but I just don't think I have it in me
to do a longer stream today.
I'm so sorry.
I'm like struggling to keep my eyes open.
I almost fell asleep with my cat like just a couple minutes
before stream.
You're spinning around like the way way like the the the wow
wow the way way I don't hopefully too isn't as buggy right I
hope so too um it's just one of those days though so I'm
really sorry if I'm like so out of it but I didn't want not
play Bioshock because if I keep putting it off, then I'll
never get to it, you know what I mean?
So, the best thing to ease my tired soul after a long day of
hard work is a Minto stream.
Ah!
What the heck?
You guys are being so nice.
It's April Fool's.
It should be saying like a silliness, you know?
Should be like a...
It's just one of those days.
all about that he says she says oh um just play as much as
you want yeah so we'll go we'll go um we'll go oh you know
we'll we'll well i'll do my best i wish i would be able to
come up with funnies for april fools but my mind goes always
blank at that time silly ghost person jaggy
being nice is our april fools joke luring me into a false
sense of security right minky is stinky april fools how dare
you you you got me silly this but yeah um i don't remember
what i was even gonna say I had an order of operations.
We'll just get into the game then.
I hope you feel better soon.
Don't push yourself.
Yeah, my cough, I think, will take a long time to recover,
but that's okay.
I think Mito is cute.
April, fools.
I don't think she is.
I know she is.
We're happy to be here watching after long days or beginning
our days.
Philip, join Princess.
Thank you.
streams are always a treat to us.
Stop!
It's April Fool's so I can hide the fact that Minto streams
make my day every make my day every day behind a vague wall
of authenticity.
What is this?
Now you guys are just being Sundere or something.
I actually can't...
No, it's not Sundere.
Wait, is it?
If you're just like, oh, I want to say she's cute, but not
really.
Cast Huey and Rick upon you, April Fool's!
No!
I want to nap so bad.
And I'm sorry, I hate, like, making excuses like this.
But again, sometimes we just have these days.
I was up until 5 a.m.
because I just, I was, like, busy with stuff.
I was working on things.
I haven't gotten a lot of April Fool's today, besides...
Oh, wait.
Oh, gosh, the chat went.
I can't, I can't, I can't scroll up the chat.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry if I missed your messages I didn't get to sleep
until 5 a.m.
which you know usually isn't a problem my like I could just
sleep in but I had stuff to do so I couldn't sleep in but
anyway regardless alright I hate complaining about stuff
like this because I feel like it's such like a you know
there's some people that don't get to sleep until 5 a.m.
and then they have to go to work at 6 a.m.
and I feel so bad you know that I'm complaining when I just
stream.
I just stream!
You're cute like 100% of the time.
No takesies backsies.
Stop it.
But, um, it was, I was about to go to sleep and then I got a
message from someone and they were like, hey, can I discuss
something with you real quick?
Are you awake?
And I was like, either that's like something kind of crazy
or like bad.
You know what I mean?
Like when someone's just like, when someone texts you and
they're like, hey, could we talk?
And I was like, what is, what, what is this?
I was nervous.
And so I was about to go to sleep and then I was like, yeah,
I'm available.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, what do you want?
It was something very, very cool.
Very, very cool.
Which I cannot talk about yet.
But big things coming.
Big things coming.
So, it's not the mere, oh, sound of your voice.
But, but, but, but, thank you.
Celebrating my birthday, Moti!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
In many ways, you're always sort of on the clock, so it's
totally understandable.
I guess that's kind of true.
Did you know NASA is launching people to the moon?
Is that what the, is that what, is that what happening?
10 that's happening i was wondering what the when the
countdown was i wanted to watch i know that it was going to
be soon though but i wanted to watch all right switching
raise i think i got this uh to heal is Oh gosh Oh also what
happened this morning Okay so for those who don't know Sorry
I'm like I guess the coffee is starting to kick in a little
bit I start getting really rambly when When the coffee kicks
in I've been on I've been on steroids for my sickness To get
over it And like you know you kind of have to Wean yourself
off of steroids to not get The withdrawals or whatever But
this morning so I tomorrow I just have one left yippee but
bye-bye bye-bye I'm unreachable unreachable for a couple
months in about 10 minutes anyway where are you going Evan
where are you going where are you going wait oh my god I saw
your cosplay the Indiana Jones one it's too good heroic rage
it's perfectly fine to vent even if you enjoy your work just
it's just frustrating that my that the medicine and my
sickness and jet lag all combined together has made it so
that i my sleep schedule is just complete doo-doo right now
we who raided thank you sorry i'm so not used to youtube
having the raid notification at the bottom of my chat thank
you so much for the gifted thank you so much for the raid Oh
my god thank you so much for the 10 gifted ha dd mega
doo-doo I love that lady Thank you so much for the 15 gifted
Miss English face thank you for the gifted Ducky thank you
for the gifted So snap that goose How much for the 5 gifted
Did you mega doo-doo Well, thank you so much for the 10
gifted.
Anyway, I have been on meds, right?
Aishin, thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Jay, thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
I have, thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Oh my gosh, you guys, thank you so much.
Thank you for all the gifts.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I've been on meds.
And I'm on my last one tomorrow, but you kind of wean off of
steroids so that you don't get withdrawals.
But today, I had to take a, it said, take one tablet before
breakfast i had a bit of a late breakfast because i did try
to sleep in a little bit more so my breakfast was actually
around like noon but right before breakfast started i
started getting super shaky and i i get that way when i
don't when i when i take the medicine so i was like oh i
haven't taken the medicine yet okay bye thank you so much
for the fun i get like i was like oh no am i feeling like a
withdrawal thing because of because i hadn't taken the
medicine so i'm scared i only have one i took my other one
for today just before stream and i have one more tomorrow
yeah i'm jacked right now you can't see because my arms are
you know hidden but i'm like i think i grew like five feet
Ah!
I'm skewed.
I'm scared of withdrawal.
So now I'm just shaking all the time.
I'm shaking right now.
This medicine makes me shaky.
It feels very strange.
I don't like it.
Anyway, okay.
Sorry, once again.
I'm lamenting about my current situation.
It's been...
It's so crazy because, like, things have been so great so
crazy all at the same time for me.
Like, all the great stuff is happening later, later on.
But right now, I think I'm going through, I mean, I'm in the
afterlife, but I don't feel like I'm in purgatory.
I think I'm going to hell.
But anyway, let's play the game.
If I die, I die.
Oh, I was holding it.
Oh, there we go.
I don't hear Big Daddy anymore, so...
I hope nobody comes and attacks me.
Is it open?
Oh, I hear people.
I'm scared.
Okay, I forgot to do a recap.
Last time!
Oh, the music's nice.
We found out that we got betrayed oh my gosh it was so uh
it's so stinky um thank you guys for the updates on the
launch but uh obviously i'm not gonna watch it because i'm
playing yeah there is no atlas that guy totally bamboozled
us and we are a giant man baby
At least that's what I thought.
Aren't we like a weird...
We grew up very quickly or something.
And...
Yeah, would you kindly is our little...
Is our little...
Uh...
Frays.
Yeah, we're his puppet.
We are the biggest baby.
I hear people talking everywhere.
And...
Now we gotta go kill...
Not Atlas.
Yeah, our trigger word!
Yeah, we're a sleeper agent.
Every time he says, would you kindly?
We have to obey.
You should lament.
No, no, no, it's okay.
Alright.
I gotta get back into it though.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
I forgot there is no fees.
Ah!
There's a guy right there!
Holy hell.
Oh my gosh.
you wait you're speaking to me frank fontaine but i can't
hear you at all why aren't the bees working
why isn't this guy dying for real though the bees
hello you are on fire electricity holy hell why is nobody
dying
that guy was the tankiest guy i've ever experienced ever
Never!
Holy!
Um, okay, there's also, I'm glad the game kind of gives me
tutorials while I'm, you know, going through it.
They're like, you might have, you might have, why were they,
oh, I think I was using electric bullets.
Oh!
I could have set them on fire here.
Do I even have that power?
I do.
Okay.
And then my bullets will do anti-personnel.
I'm pretty sure they're weak too.
Trash kill.
My vita chamber.
The bees didn't do so much though, guys.
I'm worried.
Oh!
That seems like a Oh, it absolutely is.
Who are you?
My specialty?
Run in, run in, run in, run in, run in.
Hack, hack, hack!
Oh, V is hack.
Don't remember how to save.
If you think about it, you're an alternate universe en font
terrible.
Oh my gosh, you're right!
That's so true.
I hope you're getting back into the swing of it.
I just gotta remember certain things, but I remember the
controls with most part.
Was there not a quick save?
$4.48 buyout is crazy.
It's for real though.
Okay.
I'm just gonna start saving from down here.
Oh heck.
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la da
da da Oh it's really fast, okay Okay, oh shoot shoot shoot
shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot We got this maybe?
One more long boy please?
Uh oh wait, oh No way
Everything is bad I would have had that.
I would have...
So unfair.
I had that.
I had that all on my own.
So sticking close.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shoot.
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
Actually.
Alright.
We'll go up and up.
and over and uh up and it was an april fools prank dang i
hate april fools always makes me see things that i actually
want you know what i mean oh
hey how dare you dodge oh that is a security camera now is
oh yes it is it is it It's very, it's very laggy.
Do you see it?
Something needs to oil that thing.
Oh!
It's...
What the hell is that?
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Don't shoot me!
Oh.
Shoot.
I'm pressing all the wrong buttons!
Ah!
oh no oh it's doing it okay hold on wait hold on i think i
gotta do this i got it i'm sorry guys i want to be done with
oh shoot i want to be done i'm done i'm so done with
bioshock i want to be done with this game i want to be done
with this game i'm trying to do the lossless scaling and
it's not letting me it try it tries to open the window and
then just disappears oh my god please wait oh there it is
okay oh gosh okay one second let me try again the only way
out is through what do you mean it's already running don't
lie to me
what do you mean the game is already running no it's not
please don't forget you are here forever oh my god why maybe
i can like force stop it for force stop it there we go
i don't know why it was fine okay scale all right give me a
second it might make it look funky on obs for a second and
then oh it didn't all right now let me see if this okay it
it looks fine on your end but unfortunately it like
completely ends up lagging for me so i have to then stop the
lossless scaling and hope that that works what happened for
those who okay unscale all right for those oh it's still you
see my double see the cursor up here I have double cursor
and if I like look up and try to click something it will
sometimes click out of the game I'm going
for it
I think I should play Bioshock has been really fun it's such
a shame about the tech issues I know and I you know I've had
been having so much fun with it it's just the lossless
scaling I might just have to play with it oh wait a second
oh no I didn't fix it dang it I might just...
Oh.
Hello, Windows Zone.
I might just have to...
Hmm.
It's fine if it works.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I've just have been having...
Look at this.
I tried...
Did you see...
I don't know if you can see that.
I tried to click Resume.
Look at my cursor.
I'm not even at the top.
And my cursor appears.
Oh, it's so broken.
It's just so broken.
I'm so sorry I feel like I feel like I can't be the only one
with this issue but at the same time what the how did that
do that it just I clicked steam to stop the lossless scaling
program again and then it shifted the steam icon all the way
to the right how to do that I believe in uvtuber thank you
i wonder i don't think i could learn the game though at this
point i feel like i don't i don't know i think that people
that play like fps games with a controller are crazy are
like that's i mean i know that i've done it before well i
don't actually know i like i have i have shot a gun with a
controller but it's also so crazy what's wrong with the
controller nothing i guess this game was kind of made for
controller then huh because what isn't xbox or something
don't apologize minto we know it's not your fault and let me
try the lossless scaling again let me see maybe i can max
frame latency wait hold on let me try it Turning off some of
the...
Let me try changing some of the rendering things.
Thank you, Carl Wu!
Oh, hello, Minto and Aibus.
Thank you.
This April Fool's Day has made a true fool of me.
But I hope you get feeling better, Minto.
And things get lightened up for you soon, Minto.
Love, thank you.
Hmm.
First release, Xbox 360.
No PC.
It makes sense.
But it also just doesn't feel right.
Maybe for me.
I don't know.
Okay.
Scale.
Game.
Let's... Let's... Fingies cross.
Fingies cross.
Don't... Don't notice me, please.
There's a bit of a lag.
I think I will just have to deal with it on my own.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'll do my best.
Wish on wish game.
Wait, did I just drink that?
Oops.
Wait, wasn't there something over here, too?
But does it look okay for you guys?
In OBS it looks smooth.
Maybe I play through OBS.
Oh my god.
Yeah, it looks okay.
Alright, well now you definitely can't say that I'm bad at
the game because it's not my fault.
It's literally...
I'm playing with mega lag right now.
Again.
You can't blame... Oh!
A big daddy!
Oh, he does have a sister.
There's a guy over here though.
Can I hack?
We're hacking?
Oh, I forgot to save.
Wait, oh shoot, wait, I think we're screwed.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, Ava!
Bava, Bava!
Please!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Uh, holy cow, that was so scary.
Oh, God gamer!
Yeah!
Oh, saved!
That's what I'm gonna do, too.
She's correct.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's running so fast.
Where are you?
He's like throwing it.
Wee-woo.
Is he dead?
Oh, no, he's not dead.
Where is he?
Oh, Circus of Values!
Oh.
Oh, how do I heal again?
Oh, I think I did.
Frank Fontaine!
Stop talking to me!
I'm busy!
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Did he just say I shit bigger than you?
Oh, shoot.
I don't have...
I think I'm just doing regular pistol rounds at this moment.
I don't like that.
Oh shoot, shoot, shoot, don't kill me please.
Where is he?
Big daddy, please help me, please help me right now!
Actually...
Wait.
Isn't it this one?
Help!
This guy's trying to kill me!
Oh, I killed him.
Just kidding.
Never mind.
Your services are...
Wow, you got like a little upgrade now, didn't you?
I haven't seen this outfit before.
Dang it, I killed him.
Never mind, I'm too good at my job.
The dead guy who's coming for me.
Oh, wait.
Why is there a little sister?
Is she confused?
Oh.
Alright, I gotta remember what weapons, like, I have and
everything, too.
Oh, no!
Um, exploding book.
She left me a present!
Oh, you're right!
She did!
Hold on, though.
I have to, uh...
Here we go.
We have to save first.
Yeah, it has been so long.
Uh, okay, hack, please.
I think Big Daddy is about to go Sino-style behind us.
Thanks, Big Daddy.
I almost died.
Oh my god.
Nice assist.
I feel like I should just reload at this point.
Oh my god.
Can this guy leave me alone now?
You're...
You don't...
You're actually...
You're bothering me.
When you walk around, the screen shakes and it's too much.
Yeah, no need to hack if there's nothing left to hack.
exactly stop stomping stop excuse me ma'am is this guy
bothering you oh moats are of genetics oh that's quite a
little monster fun things dug up when she does speak which
is almost a never her accent is thick and grating her hair
is filthy and she seems to wear the same mustard stain
jumper day after day oh my gosh can a girl that's like an
anime moment
naruto wears the same jumpsuit every every day nobody
complains but it's because she's a woman isn't it what were
you saying wow so much cash oh just kidding it's like seven
bucks
ah what what what
Anyway, I'm gonna go get my prize here.
We could do some upgrades.
Holy cow.
Can someone edit the turret moment into the OIST city in
Philadelphia?
Or to be continued meme.
Insect swarm 3!
The most dangerous insect swarm of all!
I feel like I have 470 I feel as if I want to Um
Wow there's still so many I haven't unlocked I feel like I
should upgrade all my like My electric bolts, my incinerate
My swarm The things that I'm using right now I think I can
Do all three
Oh Oh, yeah.
Eve and health as well.
Oh, you're right.
Health upgrade.
Okay, maybe we should...
Actually, I will do that.
And Eve upgrade.
And I will maybe...
Okay, Electro.
We can only pick one.
Maximum bees.
Ultimate electrical attacks stuns longer.
Repeated use increases heat.
Spicy.
I think Electro.
Because I use it more often than the fire.
Alright.
Poof.
Bees or bust.
Oh, I got the bees.
And I'm busting, baby.
There's a lot going on over there.
Oh.
Thank you for your $7.
My wallet.
It is full!
No!
Hold on, I'm gonna save a new save real quick.
Uh...
Stingy?
Why don't you guys have stuff in your pockets?
Who is going off anyway?
That didn't do anything to him!
Maybe it did?
Ah!
Oh shoot!
No, please, no, God, no, everything is bad.
Don't get mad at me, please.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Ah!
Who shot me?
Was that Fontaine?
Who did that?
Wait, did Fontaine do that to me?
What a jerk.
Okay, we're just gonna get out of here.
there.
It's like craziness.
My electric bolt didn't do anything to that guy, though.
I'm kind of...
Uh, I need a different weapon.
Holy cow.
You're just standing there.
Oh.
What about the circus of values, though?
Let me go grab some stuff, huh?
Let's go...
Hold on.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
Oh.
Hold on.
Sorry.
go the opposite way.
It's quiet back here now.
Ah, I don't trust it.
I don't trust it, you know?
He's also reducing my max health.
He hates me.
I mean, actually he doesn't.
Okay, can we save this?
Uh...
Where is it anyway?
Oh my goodness.
Uh...
Oh shoot, that was... that was pretty close.
I'm not gonna lie.
Uh...
Uh, yes.
Yippee!
Alright.
The Circus of Values.
Why not?
Okay.
And then there was a... there was bullets over here.
Oh, please.
Why?
Oh, okay.
We're hacking at once again.
Wait, what did they have?
Yeah, I could use more of that.
Oh, I forgot we got the crossbow.
Electric buck, I need that.
Okay.
Once again.
Save it.
And I will save before.
I'll try not to save so much.
I don't really mind it.
It doesn't take that much time.
But, I want to...
Probably...
I'm saving for these things, these situations.
Save when you want to.
Thanks, guys.
I don't know, maybe I'm just feeling a little...
Because I'm not feeling so hot.
I'm feeling extra like...
Oh, this is not salvageable.
I'm feeling extra...
Whoops!
Self-conscious or something.
Did you know that Circus of Values' voice is the creator of
the series?
It is!
I didn't know that!
uh we might be able to save this baby uh if we can get all
nope never mind oh my god
save scum is a part of the nostalgia i always get comments
on it though people being like dang she's just um
oh okay uh good news is my game is not lagging anymore uh
hold on let me take a picture of how my game looks oh what
is this
hold on what is this oh my god what is happening i'm so glad
that Actually, I'm going crazy because I know it looks
normal on your screen.
It's just my screen that it doesn't look normal.
Hold on.
Let me upload this and then I'll put it into OBS.
I think it's the lossless scaling that is vesting it up.
One moment.
One moment, please.
I'm, like, resizing it so it's not humongous.
this is funny uh show you what i see on my end real quick oh
oh no oh my whole computer is acting up okay this is great
this is really cool okay oh i love this okay cool uh so now
all of my windows are doubling This is how I see it on my
screen at the moment.
I just took a picture.
I literally took a picture with my phone of the screen.
Yeah, I'm getting hacked.
This just happened all of a sudden.
And now all of my other windows are doing the same thing.
It must be the program.
Okay, hold on.
Let's, uh, lossless scaling, unscale.
And my cursor is not...
Nope, it's doing...
Why does it feel like I'm the only one ever to have this
issue?
Now you can see my cursor is back at the top.
The gun has pants, yeah, does it?
Oh, it does look like...
Like it has Shimapan.
Oh my god, you're so right.
It's just the V-Tuber way.
Somewhere under the sea, somewhere streaming for me.
Myoshi plays a buggy game and watches the chat as they go
scrolling.
When it rains, it pours.
Yeah, Andrew is like messing with my computer at the moment.
Okay, I'll just play as this then.
One second.
I'll just play and we'll, I'll just ignore whenever my mouse
goes in Saino style, as you can see.
It's like, why are they so far?
Why are they social distancing?
My cursors.
What sucks is like when my cursor is, you can see it behind
the chat.
But when it's over there, it's like highlighting things
like, you know, like discourse.
and paint and everything so hopefully it doesn't do that
hopefully it doesn't open that stuff let your computer catch
some weird from the hack of your gov site face down happy
birthday happy birthday thank you for the super chat okay
resume i'm hacking oh i forgot that i was hacking I just was
like La la la going along my merry way Oh shoot Sorry
Actually oh my gosh wait This is great Wait this is awesome
Oh wait I can now I can like pause
Oh down here down here Oh
Wait, this is great!
Maybe it's not so bad!
I hear her footsteps, and I'm kind of wondering where she
came from.
Alright, let's grab some electric blocks.
That's all?
Where did she come from?
Oh, there she is.
Bees.
There's another guy too.
Whoa, she has some good stuff on her.
Oh.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
If I accidentally shoot, it's because I have to click back
into the game.
Bees.
Wait.
No, he's smoke-bombed!
I think he's dead.
I take pictures.
I forgot about that.
This one!
Using the game's bugs against it.
Incredible boss.
Thank you.
Sorry, I'm getting pictures of you guys while you're dead.
Aw, boo.
Oh.
I feel like it's getting worse.
I apologize in advance.
Or I just apologize at all.
Why are you coming this way?
Ignore the lives of Atlas and his parasites.
Rapture is on the rise.
Don't believe...
Randrew's lies!
Bees.
Oh, no!
My bees!
Oh wait.
I know what you- Oh, did I get a good one?
Ah!
Freeze.
Got the freeze.
Tired of being outrun by your neighbor?
With sport boost installed, get new sport boost.
Okay.
Oh.
I kind of like what I have right now.
Stole?
Bees.
Give me your money.
Is there anything in here?
Oh, there are people in here.
Oh, like this.
I'm drinking on the job.
Crossbow.
I feel like fire would be...
Oh, I remember.
Whoa, there's new music.
Uh...
How do I do this again?
Wait!
There must be something good in here.
Is that the arrow?
I think so.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, right.
Nice.
Oh, how do I get in here?
Wait, am I in?
Can I...
Wait.
You!
You farting!
I was there when you were bored.
You got a dog you gotta put down.
Breaks your heart.
You jerk!
Okay, maybe we can go in there.
the window wait oh i can liquid nitrogen can i no sir
nothing so much cake let's go so many chips give me the
money why can't i take the dollars wait how do i do my eve
is it v no v
why can't i grab the dollars what is this yeah it's a money
let me use it
just shoot until it's empty okay that's fair okay now you
grab it all right oh it's r okay thank you why can't i grab
the dollars i don't i definitely have a full wallet that's
so funky I'm money max I'm not I'm not I got it four dollars
I got it oh my bad one way in one way out sorry I said that
I wasn't gonna save scum but actually because of the way my
cursor is today?
I will.
And I'm not gonna have any shame about it.
Fontaine.
Do I have to be speedy here or else he, like, takes me out?
Is that kind of, like, the idea?
A lady and a gent!
Shame.
No shame.
Oh, there's a Vita chamber there.
Talking about soup?
Wait, where is he?
Ouch!
Oh my god, he won't stop getting me!
Oh, that's why I'm so slow.
Holy, I'm gonna die here.
Or not.
Oh, what HP in a dream?
Hey!
Please.
I'm on exploding bucks.
I
think that was his body.
Oh, sorry.
Where are my bees?
Bees.
Why aren't the bees listening to me?
Do I need to be closer?
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Ha ha.
Oh, shoot.
Can I reload faster, please?
I need to be closer.
Understandable.
Bees.
We live.
everybody somehow not quite how not quite how sure how we
did that all my things are there we go
it's so laggy
i'm hacking but yeah thank you guys thanks for the fun good
nice bit of loot yeah that was not so bad actually save real
quick we see that lag it's embarrassing who is not oiling is
oh my gosh oh
this one's a bit of a nasty one now ain't it okay this is
fine maybe I just need all the long guys in the world surely
there's one more yeah you know what game you're all You're
all right.
You know what, game?
You're all right.
What is that?
Like little glowy beetles on the wall.
The design?
The design in this location is questionable.
Hmm.
Hurry, Mr. Pop!
Uh-oh.
This way.
Yeah, get him!
I don't know what's happening.
Could I get him from here?
Where did you go?
Yeah, we'll just let him work for me and do...
Actually, does he work for me?
I don't think so.
No, he doesn't.
That's okay.
Yeah, you kill her.
You handle it.
I don't... Oh, he does work for me!
He loves me.
She runs off.
She's a scaredy baby.
I'm tired.
Waste your bubbles.
I think there's a guy around here.
Can he handle him?
You think you can just take what you want?
The Circus of Values!
Actually, we'll do it again.
We'll save again.
I'm hacking.
No, let's...
Wait, okay, let's see what we got going on here.
Not...
I can't tell much, actually.
Wait, is this...
Solvable?
Uh, definitely not anymore.
No.
Not solvable.
That's fun?
This is fine, everybody.
This is fun.
Yeah, not anymore.
Ah, you're too slow.
It's me.
I'm too slow.
Uh, let's see.
Um, wait.
Oh gosh, wait, I am too slow.
Okay, let's see.
If I...
Okay, we can redirect it down here.
They're gonna go really fast, though, through those little
tubes.
They're gonna go real fast.
And boom.
Tactical pause.
The game might love me.
Alright, can you take care of them?
I hear them.
They're freaking me out.
I think they're upstairs, though.
Oh, weapons upgrade station!
Oh my god!
Wait!
I feel like I should do my pistol damage.
Oh, I don't know.
I never used...
I just got my crossbow.
So I haven't thought about using it much.
the chemical thrower i like never use but i feel like pistol
it's easy to get bullets for it and it's cheap when you need
to buy so crossbow is a sniper that's true
i do i think my pistol i don't i don't try i accidentally
use it because get flustered and start flipping through my
weapons don't think anyone ever uses the thrower there's got
to be there's somebody no probably not huh pistol if you're
getting a lot of mileage from it hmm I'll okay I'll try to
use the crossbow more I'll try to use it more oh actually
I think I saw somebody run downstairs.
Hey there, fellas.
Oh, something got triggered.
Oh, now you're on fire.
Don't come to me.
Wait, that's not my fault.
Wait, don't...
Wait, that's not my fault you're on fire.
Don't come over here.
You're gonna get me too.
Excuse me.
Okay, it's fine.
All right, we're okay.
Try and decide what I want to...
I have, like, nothing left.
All right.
Um, I saw this.
The grenade boxes, I feel like, are always empty.
They never have anything in them.
Is a machine gun?
Where'd that lady go?
Is this her?
Yes, it is.
Let's hack the healing station.
Oh.
Okay, good.
Just in case they try to heal.
Everything is hard now.
Nothing in life.
Nothing in afterlife.
Nothing is easy.
Just really gotta make it difficult on us, huh?
Oh, that's no good.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I love when it finishes it for me.
Good thing time stops when I hack.
Shell casing.
Someone upstairs?
Eight.
Are they coming now?
Wait, okay, four.
Eight is my crossbow.
Four is my shotgun.
And then inevitably, inevitably they will switch around
because that's what happens.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
Wait, can I take that?
Oh my god, that's crazy.
Do you see what they called her, Mr. Bubbles?
She's all burnt up.
But look how little damage the fire did to him.
Kind of crazy, huh?
Mr. Bubbles.
There's something over here?
What was it?
Crystal rounds.
Thank you.
Okay, bye-bye.
Alright, there's so much happening all at once.
This guy here.
Alright.
Oh.
Okay.
My cursor is going all haywire again.
Save the sister!
Should we try it?
Should we take care of him?
Once he gets her out, maybe we could uh...
I mean, I did just save.
Why not?
Oops.
Um, I think I messed up.
Not heat seeking RPG.
Oh.
I think I messed up.
I don't remember how to beat this guy.
Am I even getting him?
Wait, let's reload.
Let's reload and try that again.
You shoot him till he dies.
I did like...
I don't even know how much health I got him down to.
I don't think I did any damage to be honest.
Okay, let's see.
There's armor piercing rounds.
Those do a good damage.
But let's do...
Take a picture.
Ah, nice one.
I'm...
Proximity mine.
Wait, now she's going the other way.
Is that for me or you?
I don't know.
I don't know what I'm doing right now.
I'm scared.
We're about halfway?
Nice.
What was it?
No, shit.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, I need to get him over here though.
Oh, okay, did reload good.
I think he's almost there.
Oh, he's so bad.
That was so bad.
All right, come here, rescue.
No, no, no,
no.
Nicely done, thank you.
It's a good thing I didn't panic.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Her head is...
Oh, oh, damn.
Oh my god.
She was...
She was in a rush, man.
I can't tell who is Mines or whose They're all over the
place What?
Again?
I think we got one though from From this level There's two,
right?
Two Little sisters?
She had a destination and a will.
she was not letting anybody get in her way so funny um okay
i have eight electric bucks so we'll stay on that and then
we'll do electricity here
that cannon bomb
can tomatoes
walls through rapture and world war ii without even a
scratch you got more than leprechauns watching over you know
his timing is absolutely impeccable in terms of being the
worst timing ever like this guy quite literally chooses
every moment where i am not able to hear him to talk to me
oh a power up
I couldn't even pay attention to what he was saying because
he's all I got was canned tomatoes because he just is
everything every noise is happening in the world he's
talking for himself we could be dead on the ground and he
doesn't even know he's just talking to us you invent
stations truly are a marvel marvel of modern engineering and
now you'll need fewer raw materials I should probably unlock
more of these like things on
store.
I need to buy more.
He's madly.
Worries he'll end up on the wrong side of grief.
That's why he commissioned a lot 192.
Fontaine said I'd better not tell anybody about the
antidote.
Not even Tenenbaum.
That's so strong.
He's inclined to listen.
So I'm going to record it.
Oh, she's listening to it!
Uh-oh.
Yes.
Oh, my gosh.
Hold on.
Something's happening.
Don't talk to me.
Team up, guys, we lost one night
What is happening?
Is she talking to me now or...
I can't hear you at all.
It said Tenenbaum, but it was re...
The game is just breaking, I think.
Get the lost 192 remedy.
So this is the...
This is the antidote he was talking about.
Oh my god.
Shut up.
Please.
The alarm goes off and he starts talking.
Why?
Oh my god.
The antidote for the mind control.
Got it.
Okay, it's the opposite direction.
This way.
Let's just follow the arrow, everybody.
Oh, what are you doing?
Bees.
I
think I'm gonna reload
Oh, oh my god There's so many explosions Everything is
happening Ryan's flesh and blood Why'd I go to the trouble
Otherwise You'd have been cut into by the first security bot
You crossed paths But not Ryan He made it so his security
would recognize his genetic structure Has somebody in there?
Okay, we're just gonna ignore him
You asshole Ah I thought I I think I sniped her, but I don't
think I got it Oh, that was so close
It's I'm not even gonna save because we'll just redo it if I
die.
It's not worth it.
It's not worth it, everybody.
No!
Please!
Oh my god.
Ah!
No!
Okay.
Everything is bad.
Are there any audio balancing options?
I don't think so.
I'm a liar.
Reverb!
This will not take places that I gave this restart.
hold on let's see sound effect volume like six we'll even
put music down a little bit because i get copyrighted
sometimes apply please
all right uh there we go oh gosh there we go
uh-huh uh-huh imagine owning a vhs rental store in rapture
what movies do they explain slicers like?
Probably like those really like the those like really crazy
what's the words?
Like TLC shows that are like so just um um um Oh, there's a
keypad here.
You know what I mean, though?
Like, the ones...
The ones that are like...
Oh, yeah, I got 15...
I hear, like, roaring.
But I got 15 plastic surgeries.
And now...
I got a baby.
There's something like that.
I hear somebody talking to, but...
Oh.
Can I...
focus on this?
Like, is there like a...
It says snipe.
Oh.
For some reason, Middlecliff reloaded it.
She's laughing.
She coming this way?
Leaky heirloom?
Sounds more like a tragedy in Ravisher.
Not soap operas, but like the reality TV shows, you know,
that are like so crazy.
Where'd she go?
I see, like, shining things.
Oh, oops.
My bad.
Can't even walk on- oh, walk on barbed wire.
Oh, I'm trapped.
Here in Rapture.
Wait, what is this, though?
What's this thing behind the Vita chamber?
And how do I get to it?
It's like up here.
Are the sound effects too low now?
Is he in a zoom?
Thank you!
That's exactly what I needed.
Thank you very much.
Actually.
I will be able to stick around for the rest of the live
stream, but I hope you enjoy the remainder of the game.
If you end up finishing it today, I don't think I will,
counselor, but thank you so much.
It's one of my favorite games, so it's been a blast
watching.
you react to it thank you i'm glad i'm so glad oh that was
so
what is that up there how do i get it oh wait wait how do i
get up here
there's also just more that's that shiny thing Wait, what
was that?
Oh!
I didn't think he'd explode.
Stupid useless grenade.
Box.
Where'd the lady go?
The one that I killed of the lady.
I'm understanding the crossbow.
Thank you everybody for turning me on to this.
We're saying, hey, you should use the crossbow more?
Take pictures.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Yes!
Increased damage!
That's huge.
I will.
Save.
And do this one, too.
It's a rifle, but old school.
I just...
I just don't know how to get up there unless I think what's
bothering the most.
No way.
This is evil.
I think we lost already.
I'll try one more.
We'll do more crossbow.
Fatal frame?
Yeah, we gotta take pictures for the fatal frame.
No!
Stop!
This one is...
Come on!
What the hell is this?
All right, one more time.
One more time.
I'll try it.
Evil patterns.
Evil.
I don't even remember what I'm doing in this game right now
at the moment.
I feel so like, la la la.
I'm just doing something.
I'm just a girl.
I'm just a girl in Rapture, you guys.
I'm like, Hello?
Where is...
I need the thing that goes opposite.
Oh, this one!
Holy cow!
Oh my god, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Is this salvageable?
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Wait.
Oh, scary, scary, scary, scary, scary, scary, scary, scary,
scary.
Scary.
Holy!
Ah!
That was so scary.
Ooh!
I wish I could find a circus of values.
That's what I was going to look for, actually.
But also, we can hack this.
So let's save again.
Oh, nope.
Just kidding.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to click that.
Let's save again.
Because I do want to invent some stuff.
Maybe we can invent some.
Yeah.
So many things.
All right.
This one is fast, though.
I remember.
Oh, my God.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Holy cow.
Oh, I just need one more Uppies.
Thank you.
Great hacking skills, Minto.
I think I'm getting better.
Boo's hound.
Drinking alcohol restores a small amount of E rather than
draining it.
Bloodlust.
Alright, let's see.
Trap bolts.
Heat seep.
Okay, I need to know, though.
Do the heat-seeking RPGs work on Big Daddy because I feel
like they might not.
They do.
Interesting.
Good to know, thank you.
They do more to humans.
He's kind of hot.
I mean, twirling my hair.
Go to Dino and Dogs Rapture location.
Go to the bathroom and rearrange the plumbing no more like
what is wrong with you all right we got a couple things here
that was fun oh that was nice nice little detour i did not
find a circus of values where is it is it down here
gonna die here make standard oil look like the piggly wiggly
under
the Atlantic you've got one hell of a head start
Circus of values.
I'm just gonna top off.
Why not?
All right, let's go.
All right.
I don't feel like dealing with this guy right now.
What?
We did get some more...
We did get some more Adam from saving Little Sister earlier.
Alright, it's right here.
Hey there fellas.
There's another guy, there's another one right here.
Alright, is it upstairs or is it through here?
No, okay I think it's upstairs.
Shut down.
We go to the top, tippy top top?
Run in, run in, run in, run in, run in.
Run in, run in.
Save-in, save-in, save-in, save-in, save-in!
But the poor sister will get her.
Eventually.
Oh,
shoot.
Oh, I built myself into a trap.
Actually, this is not solvable.
You have a sometime...
Oh, yeah, we do have the map.
We'll just follow the arrow, I think for...
I think it might be easier.
I hear there's a person over there too.
I'm a little bit nervous.
Oh, nice.
Oh, yeah.
Where'd she go?
The zoom is kind of insane.
Like it's, they're like, you little zoom.
Damn it.
It's kind of tough to use though.
There's like a tiny, like a...
Very zoom.
The zoom also like messes with your head.
Kind of like, ooh.
Lots of frag grenades.
things that I forget to use are you coming upstairs don't be
for real right now why what business do you have here
live first try
oh oh dang I should have taken a picture of him while he was
like while he was like shaken what's shaken bacon you ever
look at the people that are oh hold on paparazzi between
Fontaine and his little German beanhole this
is beyond the understanding of this paparazzi the graveyard
oh to be Don't spout up in a yard again.
5744, everyone.
5744.
So the door down there, I guess.
Um, but before we do that...
Home of Bridget Tenenbaum!
Why is it set up like this?
Uh...
Oh, oops!
Let's stop.
Oh my gosh, that's so funny.
I pressed 3 instead of F3.
Oh, wait.
Oh no!
I was trying to pick it up!
That's what I'm saying.
Oops.
There we go.
Okay, I think I did it.
No, the first aid, it's still around.
We got this.
We could still get it!
Wait, I can even use the bathtub?
There wasn't very good stuff in here though.
Oh, I can't even pick it up though, I just realized.
Oh, that's a spot- this.
Oh, I didn't need to use that either.
That's fine though.
Armor.
Antipersonnel.
It's like right around the corner.
What the heck is going on in here?
Nothing left but nothing, is that what he said?
Bees.
Finally, he says!
Good job, bees.
Look at my home, torn apart by Fontaine and his pigs.
Finally, bees.
The subtitle's so funny.
There's two exclamation points, aren't one.
I will not believe me, but there was a time when this place
was all so beautiful.
Really?
I believe you.
Get the law of 192 remedy.
Aw, the sad music.
I'm sorry that your home is messed up.
But like also, why are you just keeping money?
on your shelves all right is it down here I think I actually
am going the right way that's crazy the music how I forgot
to ask you guys how is the audio now it doesn't seem it
seems quiet and loud it's always okay
I'll like set it I put it up just a tad okay I'm trying to
save but it's gonna click out of the game there we go okay
let's see all right that's crazy that's good oh it only took
until part six to fix it you don't want them ah
Bioshock.
Actually, listen five of any FPS.
Don't just stand still in the middle of a doorway.
Wait!
Oh.
Which one is it?
F5.
Which?
Where is it?
Oh, there.
Oh, is it...
Oh, no, I'm getting electrocuted.
Oops.
Well, that's okay.
That's fine, actually.
Oh, it's a good save.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, it's a safe.
Sigis.
Sigourits.
Bandages.
We'll apply those.
Alright.
Now we actually save.
This is fine.
Yeah, it's because I was in water.
I thought...
That's why I had the bees on.
Oh, my God.
No, I forgot it's one of these.
holy oh my god no it's not possible oh i just accidentally
clicked out of the game
okay that's my it was so fast it was impossibly fast you're
impossibly fast and your skin is cold to the touch you say
you're 17 how long have you been you say you're forever 19
hack.
Hot dog!
Baby!
Let's go.
This way?
Thank you.
Oh, we're just in...
Wait.
Is this the same room?
Oh, yes, it is.
Andrew Ryan is kind of an idiot for letting this obvious
gangster type of guy come to his city with no government or
law.
I, you know, he's probably just Jell-in.
Thanks for the hot dog.
Auto-hack, my beloved.
I just don't have it in me today.
I'm not telling me this way.
Oh, okay.
It is.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me just save real quick.
Sorry.
I know I just saved.
Actually, did I just save?
I don't remember anymore.
Yes, I did.
Okay.
I saved literally a minute ago.
That's so funny.
Was there anything over here?
There was this guy.
You're dead dead?
What's in here?
Besides beautiful music.
Abandoned apartment.
Oh my god.
Wait, this is actually so messed up.
It's the whole family!
I've
got a key.
They're taking their food.
Oh.
Oh, here!
Let's do bees.
Bees.
I'll be a pathetic woman.
Oh, man.
I can't see anything.
It's hard to see.
Oh.
He died to the bees.
What an idiot.
The whole family.
kind of scary in here though oh another safe auto hack
do you end up getting taco bell last night me though if so
what you get oh my gosh i went to taco bell and it was
probably closer ish to midnight by the time i was able to go
you think you're some kind of hero i ordered you up from
suchong like a chinese dinner a little from what else is in
here a little from column a a little from column b what do
you plan on going back to hold on i'll explain in a second
your phony dreams putting you out of your misery will be the
nicest thing anyone's ever done for you wait this one goes
to there Ah, it's, uh...
They knew that was gonna happen, didn't they?
We'll make a day out of it.
I don't know where she is.
Um...
But yeah, I went and, um...
It was so bad that...
That doesn't seem good to be next to the, uh...
Stove.
Uh, it took it took a good like 40 ish minutes or so for my
food to get done so i did get home until like 1 a.m i was i
was so hungry i was like damn i possessed the most unlucky
person ever
i heard that lady i just don't know where she came from she
maybe it was above us
I'm seeing their shadows
No Taco Bell is worth that And you know it really sucks
Because you know The body I possessed Took the drive-through
And so Once you're locked in You Oh wait we gotta go down My
bad There was a car behind me I couldn't leave.
So, it just, uh...
Yeah.
What was it?
5733?
I was trapped in the drive-through for like 40 minutes.
Just leave them in the car.
I was, I was, I was, I was, you know, I was, uh...
What's the word?
I was, um...
It sunk cost fallacy at that point.
Was that it?
No.
5744!
Oh, thank you!
Uh, that's good?
They say to save one life is to save the world entire.
Every time?
But it is you who are their savior.
Will you stop here?
Or will you deliver them from this terrible city at long
last?
Why is this my job?
Fun's for not Taco Bell.
Thank you.
You're literally the only one left?
God damn robbery.
We got the bot shutdown thing here the
market will come back.
Oh, no, bro.
It's so over for you.
Oh, there he is
Oh, well, uh
Okay, cool
I like the crossbow I Think I'm a fan
I think.
I'm a fan.
I think I understand the hype.
I should have never doubted you guys.
Wait, where is it?
Oh.
It's a where?
Oh, gosh.
Did I get it?
Yes.
Lots going on.
Oh wait.
Save.
Oh, my cursor's getting all crazy again.
Taco Bell, we're like Taco Hell.
I mean, it hit the spot, I'm not gonna lie.
It was exactly what I wanted.
Didn't you like the crossbow in Half-Life 2?
Maybe.
I can't remember.
Oh, come on.
Don't give me an unsolvable one.
You jerk?
You hater?
Yeah, it was tasty.
It did hit the cravings.
Oh, please.
There we go.
Okay.
Actually, this way.
At least it's slow.
My goodness.
Oh, wait.
I'm losing my touch.
how does it how does it taste no i went taco bell just don't
go to the one i went to don't have me possess you you'll be
waiting in line for 40 minutes apparently wow a bear
wow all right let's grab some stuff let's we do a bit of
looting
Tootin' tootin' Oh, oh, no!
Micmac!
Thank you so much for the gifted!
Alright, I'm gonna save real quick again.
Oh wait, well, yeah, I'll save because I did the...
I did the camera roll.
Taco Bell near me is exactly the same.
I think it's universal.
It might be.
It did inspire my April Fools.
Rapture was a candy store for a guy like me.
Guys who thought they knew it all.
Dames who thought they'd seen it all.
The dames.
The circus of values.
Something always has to interrupt this guy, I swear.
I think Rapture probably was really awesome but kind of dark
you know not just like just dark in terms of like oh i guess
i didn't need that oh vodka dark in terms of like the act oh
oh i think i'm drunk oh i heard i had a merlot and i had
some vodka i got drunk a little bit humidity too high it
seems like that absolute like 1950s like in the year 2010
we'll all be living under the water and you'll be there too
and it'll be grand old time you can just look at all the
cigars wow you know you and grandpappy sit and watch the
fishies swim around just bought the max membership for dead
set too had a bit of a rough day so hopefully your stream
contribute a bloody ocean thank you i'm so sorry i have a
bad day though sad saps these sad saps they come to rapture
thinking they're gonna be captains of industry but they all
forget that somebody's gotta scrub the toilets what an angle
they gave me
of soup and they give me their lives who needs an army when
i got fontaine's home for the poor we gotta kill this guy
sorry it gets me it gets me every time are there two of them
two of them two of them two of them
One of them.
This is getting out of hay.
Oh, shoot.
You know, I think we have to kill this guy.
This guy sucks.
I'm tired of them.
Would you kindly kill yourself?
Fontaine.
Nobody else?
Please don't take that out of context.
Oh,
this is good.
Whoa, whoa, we could get white, we could get white girl
voices.
We'll be jumping and dancing on the pool table.
We would be, oh, I kind of want to do it though.
I want to try this one.
Woo!
Black girl wasted!
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
Oh it's not possible.
I already lost.
We can do this, we can do this.
I just need the right thing!
To come through and it doesn't!
These ones get really...
These ones, I think, are like...
Yeah.
The saves are the reason you get the...
Evil.
The saves are the reason you get the hacking buffs.
Because otherwise, it's freaking impossible.
Just keep re-rolling until I get, like, a perfect...
Oh, yeah, there's no way.
There's no way.
And I keep...
I'm clicking so fast I click out of the game and it throws
me out of my focus.
Oh, why did I even think that would work?
Oops!
Not bad.
They're such a scam.
They all, honestly, at this point, I don't even find this a
fun challenge anymore.
Alright, one more time, one more time.
Oh, I accidentally took out the electricity.
There's no way!
I like...
Alright.
Oh, whoops.
I forgot to actually...
Auto-hack it.
We'll take cash.
This isn't even fun one more time though.
Whoa!
I got bamboozled.
Looking.
Electric Flesh When we said electric flesh was the ultimate
in electricity enhancements, it turned out to be premature.
New electric flesh, too, is even better.
Be the shocker, not the shock-ee, with electric flesh, too.
Oh, oops, wait, uh, wait, wait, wait.
What did I have?
I had Angry Man Oh, less damage from fire And more damage
when you use fire Electric fish You take damage Less damage
from electricity Deal more damage when you use electrical
attack So actually I'm going to switch to this one Actually
it was a good switch Yeah, we'll do that then I like when I
have telekinesis It's just a hand.
It's just like a grippy...
He's like, I'm gonna grab ya.
I'll do it.
Don't say I didn't warn ya.
Oh, we got the lot 192!
Okay, wait.
Let's, let's, uh, let's figure this out real quick.
Wait.
Let's save real quick.
And also, we will, um...
all these body horror plasmids then just a hat it really
just takes me out of like the whole okay we have four yikes
okay that's not great let's see maybe my machine gun okay we
got a lot of machine gun round actually we'll do the no
we'll do the regular ones for now should be okay we'll
get the uh we'll get the uh Antidote.
After these messages.
Oh!
Okay, okay.
It was this way around.
Fancy.
Anything in here?
The toilet is so tucked away.
This is this.
This looks like a Sims house.
This looks like a Sims house that I would have made if I
were like, you know, Like eight years old playing the Sims
for the first time and I only I only knew big and I did not
know how to decorate
I'm gonna waste I'm gonna get have you have a giant water
bill Fontaine Mother load mother load mother load Oh, I
drank it.
Oh, oh, I'm better now Now!
Yes.
The compound is taking hold.
The effects of the mental suggestion are now gone.
Security bullseye.
But there will certainly be side effects.
Your plasmids have become unstable and you are temporarily
unable to choose which one you have equipped.
Oh, okay.
Oh, Phoebe!
Thank you!
Phoebe hath buzzing in.
Hello!
Hey, KFCF2, thank you for that gift and Phoebe, you were.
singing, weren't you?
Doing karaoke?
Let's see, let's try this extra like, get this!
Moe, moe, boo, o'clock, o'clock, o'clock, o'clock,
everybody!
Hey, Ami, don't hope you have so much fun today.
Yeah!
I'll see you later.
I'll see you later tonight.
Karaoke, yeah, it was so good.
I bet because Phoebe!
Oh my god, wait!
Don't leave!
You guys, if you have not seen Phoebe's April Fool's, Go to
Phoebe!
Go to Phoebe!
Channel!
Phoebe Chan Chibi Channel!
And go watch.
It's a demo touch.
The cover is too good.
Actually, hold on, let me link it.
Let me link it.
Phoebe, it's a demo touch.
Oh!
Where, where, where, where, where, where?
Where, where, where, where, where?
There she is.
Free Bray.
Phoebe's.
Oh, thank you guys for all the gifted Phoebe's.
Amazing cover.
Please watch.
Oh.
I hope that doesn't link to a Jake Paul video.
We pin message You were so kawaii and uke mint Hope you
liked it I loved it Oh, totemo super duper Suki Super duper
Tano-shii Ultimate kawaii Making me want some mochi ice
cream Nya
Super duper, duper, daisky, niya!
It was so amai and so sugoi.
I don't know what these sounds are, but I want Pocky now.
Pocky, niya!
That's the ultimate ultimate sugoi snack, niya!
Pocky!
I could eat Pocky!
for asa gohan and hiru gohan and ban gohan oh totemo super
duper oi shi poki
you're too good at this
sometimes sometimes i i uh i will save the box of the pocky
yeah because it says it says made in japan yeah and
if it has a paki written in japanese i cut it out and i i
save it in my scrapbook when did you turn into a kawaiiko
chan comic
okay but that's based on a true story if something when i
when i when i was a baby wish if something said made in
japan i would like keep the box or
i would like oh
it hurts it's just one of those it's one of those one of
those uh right of passages that true weeaboo go through okay
everybody i think my ochi's cooked it's serious like i am a
i am a bona fide i have no bones i only have ectoplasm but i
am a bona fide Wee-boo.
Yeah.
All right, we're back to plasmids.
Our plasmids have become unstable and we are temporarily
unable to choose which one we have equipped.
Wait, so what is a security bullseye?
I don't even know what this one is.
Hey, I didn't get called a reincarnated Japanese princess by
a taxi driver for nothing.
I know I'm dead, but I guess he didn't realize, maybe.
It's probably one of those ghost stories where, like, a taxi
driver picks up a ghost.
And then he looks in the mirror and they're gone.
What?
Yeah, that happened one time.
I was getting taxied back to my maid cafe.
And he was just like, wow.
You know, and I'm just like, like ah ha ha ha ha ha and he
says you know
he's like you know yeah you you're so in tune you you just
you your your japanese is just too good you must i wonder if
that's like a pickup line he uses for foreigners who knows
but he's like you must have been a japanese princess in a in
a in a former in a former life he saw all your past
lifetimes like the avatar
and i'm how i i how okay but if a taxi driver tells me that
who who am i to say no sir no sir you're so wrong no sir
there's no way that like how he has all the wisdom honestly
I trust taxi drivers in Japan so much because driving there
is the highest form of skill taxi drivers have seen it all
that's what I'm saying yeah plus he's Japanese he must be
right so guys I was formerly Japanese, probably.
And also a princess.
So you must respect me.
Yeah.
Oh, porn says.
Formerly Nippon Himeña.
Oh, man.
What have I come to?
I am a former Japanese princess, and now I'm an anime girl
maid.
I have Digressed.
Regressed?
Wait.
Something about the drawing style of that video.
You linked?
Oh yeah.
It should awaken memories.
We will tweet.
Tweet you like a princess always.
Oh thank you.
Thank you.
You mean upgrade.
I'm the superior life form now.
Death form?
Ghost.
Can we get a cute Ojo-sama laugh from Minki-hime?
That's a Minki Ojo-sama to you!
Peasant!
You can't see, but my hand is up, and my pinky is out.
Huzzah!
Okie dokie.
Plasmids.
We're back to plasmids.
I don't know what this one is.
I might die.
Something's going on.
Good.
Now go find Su-Chung's lab in Artemis' suite.
In there, no doubt there will be more of this slot 192.
Okay.
Whoa.
What am I now?
Oh, I'm Winter Blast.
Oh, I really have no control.
Wait, I don't even know how to use these.
Apologize for our past bad behavior.
Oh, me!
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted!
Oh, can I go through?
Uh, why won't the door open?
Is it because, uh...
Oh!
Oh, it's like an emergency thing.
If the alarm's going off.
Target, dummy.
Oh, this one makes a dummy.
man wait i kind of want to see oh look at that wait what do
i look like oh
wait i'm hideous why do i look like a oh why do i look like
a zombie
i can't i actually cannot go through until the alarms are
off so i don't know what to do i guess it's almost over
truly prince is coded with Leading behind a guarded door.
I can't do anything!
Oh, electric bolt!
Let's go.
Oh, shoot.
Oh!
Don't shoot me.
Uh, I have to go this way back again.
Holy cow.
Oh, shoot.
Enraged!
What does that do?
Oh, Target is already enraged.
Oh, my god.
That was craziness.
It says I have to go.
Oh, I was over here.
Oh, it meant the elevator.
Of course it did.
Okay, we're fine.
We're enraged right now.
Or they...
Did they get this one?
Yeah, alright.
Oh, they cleaned up.
Oh, you.
What am I?
Oh, incinerate!
Okay, let's go.
I hope I'm going to go in the right way.
I hope I'm going the right way.
More aggressive, but receive more damage.
Bing!
All right.
Alright.
We're going all the way back through here?
Oh my god.
Damn it.
Ouch!
I think I got him.
What am I?
Oh, hypnotized big daddy.
Bro's going- why was he crying?
Oh!
Oh, dang it.
I'm gonna heal again.
For cheaper this time.
No!
Oh, please.
Yes!
What am I now?
Insect!
A rapture reminder.
What's this?
Oh, the gene bank.
Doesn't do much for us right now.
What was that?
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna say real quick.
The bees!
In here?
Oh, wait.
Is there anything?
Oh, nope.
They just tell me to go places, and I just follow the arrow.
You hate the B hand?
It looks so creepy.
I think I hate the frozen one the most because it reminds me
of like needles sticking out of my hand.
It's so icky.
Games, oh, the game's saved.
I didn't even, oh, we are.
Oh, I haven't tried this one before.
I don't know what it does.
We could try it.
On somebody, baby.
Fragrinette.
Are you...
Oh, you do work still!
What's happening here?
I was so angry when I came down here, but my...
My god.
Let me go to the place.
I saw a woman climb over the fence trying to escape.
One of Lion's guards pointed at her, and she lit on fire.
Just like that.
What's happening here?
Security bullseye.
I don't know what this one dies.
I don't know what you do.
Uh, actually...
Well, yeah, I'll save anyway.
I know, like, the game just saved, but...
Oh, sorry.
Clicked out of the game.
There we go.
Poor Diane!
She seems confused.
Let's see.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I don't know if I can do this one.
Oh, no, I cannot.
Oh, screw it.
Let's just try it one more time.
Wait.
Can I do this one too?
Oh, dang it.
I tried.
I did miss a little sister in the previous stage.
I do know that.
It's okay.
We can always...
We probably have to go back.
I don't know.
We'll figure it out.
if push comes to shove and it's like oh my gosh i cannot
keep going without getting some little sisters then we will
you know i need i need i need ah no wait what just happened
oh the security alert uh i was about to say are they coming
for me i think they were glasemans may fail you but the shot
i don't know the shotgun sometimes these guys are really
tanky i think the shotgun works much better i mean obviously
it works better if you're up close but dang it like you
gotta be close you know what i mean uh shoot shoot shoot
shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot please no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no oh i
short-circuited there
This one's a tough one.
Oh, shoot.
Please, please, please, please, please, where's it?
Upie!
Bioshock is a series where difficult equals more HP.
Yeah!
Those are always like...
Man, you know, it's just...
Okay.
Uh...
This one is hard for me for some reason.
I don't know why.
I'm struggling.
I'm struggling hardcore right now.
There we go.
Maybe.
Yes.
Uh...
Over.
Okay!
What do we got?
We'll take a first aid kit, film, pistol rounds, we'll grab.
All right.
All right, since we just did that, a circus of value.
Go-go gadget auto-hack.
Most of them I'm able to do.
It's really the best friend dog food.
It becomes the, um, the safes that actually become
impossible.
Be on the lookout for illegally imported goods.
I hear big daddy.
Winter blast!
These don't seem so random.
I think they're going in an order.
Time to go, Mr. B.
Wow!
Mr. B.
I wish I could crouch.
Thank you!
Oh!
Adam.
Wait, what if I put myself like right there?
Oh, oops.
He's dancing.
Can I go around you?
Thank you.
But here's something.
I can't tell if it's him or not.
Oh, please!
Oh, of course she's gotta be.
Of course she's gotta be immune.
Let's hack.
I think there will be lots of guys around here, so we'll
start hacking this.
Oh, please.
My cursor is getting worse and worse.
Is the computer okay?
could be better.
I don't know if you mean mine.
Oh, this is not possible.
And this one is also...
You know what?
Screw it.
I don't care anymore.
I don't... Oops.
I don't want to do it.
I lied.
Cough sounds less intense.
Yeah!
At this point, I wonder if it's, like, allergies.
Not only allergies, but yeah.
Oh, nice.
It's loaded.
What is it?
You're sick.
Got pet bugs?
Gene traitor.
What is going on here?
Chocolate's better than grapes or grapes?
Better than wit?
Oh my god, you're gonna mess up my shot, please, Big Daddy.
Oh, come on.
I messed up my shot.
Stop!
I like that they explode.
Oh, we're on incinerate now.
Okay, very cool.
I keep forgetting to take pictures.
We can take...
Uh...
Whoa!
She could smell something you guys.
First aid kit, I smelled that.
Capital punishment!
Wow, there's a lot of first aid kits around here.
Why?
It's too dangerous to re-engineer your plasmids the state
spontaneous put you in you'll just have to make do is what
you have okay one of the gorillas at the gate to let me in
it's awful in here to my right i can see a dead woman lying
in the street everybody just walking by her like she isn't
there but i noticed something spray painted everywhere atlas
lives i don't know what it means but something tells me it's
Oh, she's like mid-action, too.
Okay, um, what was I doing?
Oh, we got bees?
Okay, nice.
We're searching.
We're eating.
She's drinking.
I'm challenging.
There's a lot of stuff here.
Why is that?
I almost want to get this guy.
Alright.
Let's see if we can get this guy.
Maybe we can take him down.
Maybe.
Oh,
I'm on telekinesis because it's freaking...
Uh, shoot.
I'm in bad shape right now.
I hate that when it switches it.
It, um...
It changes it automatically puts me on my plasmid instead of
my weapon
Yippee Adam improved every aspect of man except his
character Perhaps there is a plasmid that can grow the
spirit perhaps in your DNA the secret life I sent a little
one with some goodies to help ease your burden Where oh
Thank you He is the one who helps us Yeah, who Armored shell
too and the bullets wait.
Oh nice wait, that's huge
Wait, that's huge.
Oh, be careful Nice that's when we actually had save Oh I'm
trying to get my cursor correct.
There we go.
Oh, there she goes.
And we have all this stuff.
I probably should.
Gene bank.
I saw no circus of...
Wait, there was all the first aid kits all over the place.
I need those.
I'll take them now.
Oh, wasn't there more?
I could have sworn I saw... Oh, hello.
Oh, there's one, yeah.
Was there one over here?
No, I took it already.
Alright, cool.
Winter blessed!
We'll go... I'm not really good, okay.
I am having fun!
I'm just trying to...
Get used to it as well.
Oh.
I can't take that out.
Oh, no, no.
Okay, we'll go down this way.
Evil.
Evil, evil game.
Target,
dummy.
If I do this, will it start attacking it?
Oh, that's so funny, but now I'm trapped.
Do I have to wait until I have electricity?
Ah!
Maybe I could fool it like this.
And hack it?
Holy!
Wait.
Save.
Okay, okay.
We got this.
Oh, Winter Blast would have worked.
Would it?
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, oh, please, okay.
Okay, I really just screwed up my whole thing.
Hold on one second, guys.
It's rearranging.
You know how you have, like, your taskbar and you have your
little icons up top?
Every, it's re- my cursor has slowly been rearranging them,
it seems.
Okay, we have this.
Okay, maybe this is fine.
I have one down here.
Okay.
Okay, maybe this is okay.
I need a...
Okay.
The cursor has a mind of its own.
That's not your enemy!
What are you doing?
That's literally me!
I thought you were on my side now.
What are we attacking?
Oh, these are flowers!
Are these like a bunch of missing people?
Hmm.
What?
Are we attacking, actually, though?
Like, what is the...
I don't want to get out, birthed.
Oh, no.
I have, like...
Wait, I have, like, one shot to do this.
I'll do another save.
Damn it!
Help!
Wait, my... Oh, my gosh, please.
Please, game.
Don't be like this.
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is very much less than
ideal
i am very dependent upon having only long guys which i do
not
wait hack we'll try again lock in i'm locked in i'm locked
in i'm locked in ish
Ish.
Wait.
Oh my god.
That's...
But yeah, but this also puts me in a scenario where I can
only have long eyes.
Wait, I just need one more please!
Please, Gabe!
Ah!
Heck yeah.
What does it see?
Oh.
We'll just let him pan.
We'll just let them handle it.
Oh, I have too much money.
She looks alive.
I don't know about this one.
Hey, hey, hey, team, have we checked her?
Have we, have we checked the one that's literally sitting
straight up with her eyes open?
I don't know, team.
We've attacked everybody else.
Nice, first aid kit.
We love to see it.
The money.
Oh, wait.
I should save after it.
Sorry.
I know I saved so much.
I said I wouldn't apologize for it, but I am.
We can have burnies.
Oh, he's dead.
Lucky.
I have too many.
Oh, what is this?
Oh.
I have too much money.
Please, Circus of Values.
I need you.
Can I get in here?
I can still search.
Oh, nice.
Yes, I know.
Bees.
Oh, Circus of Values!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, that's...
this is not bad.
This is quite bad.
I can't do much.
I'm gonna show you what it's like to look.
Okay it's just the one I think.
Is it?
Okay.
I'm worried we're doing
I'm gonna go right on the other.
Telekinesis?
Mary, yes, I know.
The guy's walking on the ceiling.
Also, there's like a dead body.
There's like a family guy posed.
Guy right there.
Nice pickup.
Thank you.
Look at this one, too.
The shadows on the ceiling are killing me.
Alright, I want to go this way.
I just feel safer.
this way, but I have to get around first.
Cyclone.
I don't know what this one does.
I wish it could give me...
I just want to get this taken care of.
So I wish it would give me electricity.
Singing splicer is back.
It's so annoying.
It levitates people.
But only people, not corpses.
It looks so pathetic.
I don't know why it looks so lame.
Wait, what is security bullseye?
Wait.
What is this one?
I'm going to test it.
Oh, you let them walk into it.
Oh.
Oh, I don't think it did anything.
What does this do?
Oh, you throw it at someone and the bots go after them.
Ah, that's fine.
Is there anyone that we could have?
Wait, this won't get me, right?
Do I see anyone that I could throw at?
Sorry, I just wanna... Wait, I can just go up to it.
I forgot.
I forgot that I don't have to electrify it.
I'm stupid.
Sorry, guys.
I was like, wait a second.
Who are you?
Uh.
Why is this one nice and slow?
I don't feel any stress.
Just focused on a different task.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's just too goofy.
I can use the phone?
Hello?
19?
Okay.
Somebody's house.
Alright.
Now what are we doing?
More film.
For the Bible tells me so.
Nois.
Useless grenade box as usual.
Alright, let's go upstairs to this guy then.
Not the target dummy.
Actually that one did save my butt though.
Sorry I'm saving because I cut the camera.
Let's do my crossbow.
How...
Is this pot...
Do I have a...
An unlock that I forgot about?
Because how am I seeing people?
I don't quite understand.
It's probably a lighting bug.
Probably, right?
It's so... It's too funny.
It's so funny.
Electroball!
My favorite!
Free clinic!
Oh wait, this is...
Yeah, that's the guy.
This is where I need to go.
Okay, but before that...
Let's search around here.
And I do want to go into the...
I do want to go into the...
What do you call?
That was unfair.
I hit that.
The apartment that was at the very bottom.
I forgot to save.
I think this is the turret that tries to kill you.
Of course.
Oh, oh, geez.
Okay, wait.
Panic, panic, panic, panic, panic, panic, panic.
Wait.
Oh, no, no, no, wait.
Panic, panic, panic, panic, panic.
We're not panicking.
Uh, nope, I could have gone around maybe.
Wait, wait, wait!
I didn't see the skinny guy.
I didn't see him.
That's okay.
That's okay!
She panicked.
What the heck was that?
That was a crazy sound.
Ugh.
Alright, I guess so.
away then this away then this away oh not that oh all right
then down away and that away and up away up up and
the pause is actually not a trick
I actually, it's kind of...
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm gonna die.
I think I'm gonna die.
Oh, shoot!
Oh my god.
Just kill him.
Just kill him!
Just get him already, please!
When we do leave, it's gonna be so nasty.
It's gonna be so nasty.
Yeah, the turret had my back asterisk.
Oh my god, we're setting the place on fire!
Circus of values.
Didn't I see one?
Or am I crazy?
I thought I saw one and I was like, Circus of values!
And then maybe I just didn't.
Grab a...
Red means scary.
There's so much film in here!
Hypnotize Big Daddy.
I've been unable to watch your stream because of how busy
work is.
Don't look, don't apologize at all!
I've been listening to your voice, hope you're having fun.
Thank you, Bloody Ocean!
Good luck with work!
Oh, two med kids, that's huge.
Um, I wish I could spend all my money, though.
You know what?
Maybe I will use this.
100.
I had three.
Bees.
What did that say?
Oh, I thought it said streamer trunk.
It's like, no way.
What does a streamer need to do?
trunk for my
cursor is getting worse and worse you guys not to alarm you
at all
I think I've been saying that cool that was this telekinesis
did I look it through here more money money that I can't
take All right, so...
Eh, whatever, I'll use it.
Can't...
Can I go up?
No.
So I can't go up anymore.
This is the highest we can go, I guess.
For now.
Okay, cool.
So let's go back down, actually.
All the way to that first apartment, and then we'll go back.
into the clinic actually actually though maybe we go into
the clinic first so I could get rid of this stupid this this
stupid change my plasmids thing I don't know what to do here
actually though because there's a security camera and also
there do you think I could jump over that here let's try it
I'm gonna run and jump.
We're gonna run and jump.
Yeah, the power roulette is really ash.
That's right there.
Okay.
Which way are you telling me to go, game?
It's telling me to go that way.
Aha.
Very nice.
Nice park.
Core, thank you.
I
don't think that did anything.
Chemical thrower can freeze the turret.
So it can!
Look at that!
It's frozen!
Wait, that's too cute!
I thought that was the circus.
Are you still there?
I didn't save.
Rose and things are easier to hack.
Oh, because they're slower.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
I...
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot,
shoot.
Saved but barely.
I don't know about easier, guys.
Easier is a strong word, maybe.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Do I have one?
Okay.
Sorry, I used my pause hack.
That one.
Oh,
of course now I get the winter blast.
Oh, wait, that's not moving.
Excuse me.
I'm stuck.
Can I go under it and hack it?
Yes, I can.
It makes the juice move a bit slower if they're frozen.
Oh.
I kept...
my cool I kept my cool oh wait ah it's fine sorry oh I
wasted a lot of time okay great I was like wait I can freeze
it real quick but um actually is this solvable is this even
solvable we'll try wait let's see I don't even mean to do
that down down down I have no double down I I cannot double
down.
I am being rejected of my...
Wait, I only need one down.
Wait, oh, I clicked out again on accident.
Same, thank you so much for the super chat.
Wait, I actually might be able to do this.
This might be kind of crazy.
Wait, this might actually...
Wait, it's doable.
That was crazy.
Paperbacks, thank you for the gift, and Dorgo, thank you for
the pocket, and...
Oh!
I got raided?
Thank you!
Thank you.
I'm suffering a little bit.
If it looks like I'm cheating, it's not.
The game actually just hates me.
Wait, who's coughing?
Who's coughing in here?
Protection bomb.
Oh.
There's a ghost.
Plagium in the lot, 255.
Dr. Su-Chung, client Ryan Industries.
day i can't seem to get the damn big daddies to imprint on
the little brad jesus welcome to membership thank you bond
is just a not fun thing
maybe if i modify the genetic sequence sure sure oh
that felt so good oh my god you stupid head oh it's his
drill wait that was so deserved that was so deserved oh it
felt so good yeah yeah yeah that felt good what's in here
then oh he had a little ghost just for some rubber hoses
okay I'm gonna save because it might go crazy mode on us
again right before we pick up the...
Wait, can I pick it up?
Thank you.
Now you are having freedom!
Ah, freedom!
Nuchang's drugs should have no hold on you.
Oh my god.
All of them are all... they're all reconfigured too.
Go to Point Prometheus!
Oh.
Oh, this door is not open.
It feels so good to be me.
He's just walking.
Me?
Wait, why is he?!
What did I do?
Yeah, thank you.
Oh, wait, where is he actually?
We'll let them handle it.
Oh, it was his own drone!
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow!
Me too,
I want to help!
Or something?
There's so much going on, I can't tell at all.
There's bullets.
Literally everything.
Everything is happening.
Anyway, what's in this room over here?
I wish I could spend my...
Oh, I thought that was a person standing there.
Skinny person.
Skinny head.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, nice, thank you.
Search, search.
Oh, thank you.
There's so much money I can't pick up.
This is so...
Please.
Stupid.
Now crush him.
Now kiss.
Crush him.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
slow painful death why is it so gentle why is it still
pushing him stay away from me stop stop medical expert here
you'll heal your injuries in the blink of an eye with the
new a medical expert three medical expert first aid kids
give you Much more health.
It's more terrifying that way.
There's so much money I can't pick up.
Min playing FNV's Dead Money DLC.
What's FNV?
What's that?
Well, honestly, do I even...
I guess the camouflage probably works and I'm not realizing
it maybe.
Oh, Fallout New Vegas.
Oh, we'll store it for now, though.
All right.
More cash.
I'll take the bandages now.
Thank you.
Okay.
Did I search you?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, he set that up.
Oh, you son of a...
You stupid...
You!
It doesn't work through the window.
Okay, but he can't hit me and I can't hit him, so it's
mutual.
Time to go find that.
I really need to find the circus, like, bad, bad.
I have not played any Fallout game before.
Oh.
Destroying something up there.
I love our sound effects when we get hurt
It's too funny Let's see
All right this actually is pretty open
Oh, shoot.
Do I have a way that I could do this?
Yes, I do.
Saved.
Good morning, Nito.
Good morning.
Three and onwards are kind of like oblivion, but with guns.
No!
Don't tell me that.
I've always wanted to play Fallout because the lore just is
too interesting, right?
The lore seems so awesome.
them.
All I want to do is meet someone.
Meet someone.
Where are they?
Don't shoot my guy!
Oh, never mind.
They didn't get him.
They got him.
I assisted.
You think there's a circus of value in here?
In their apartments?
It'd be kind of awesome to have a instant, everybody's
floating around.
An instant grocery store.
Here's $10 for Fallout New Vegas playthrough.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Strike.
The TV show looks good.
Haven't watched it, but it's on my to-do list.
Can anyone concur that it's any good?
Juvent.
Which means there might be values in here.
Merlot.
That's a corpse.
That guy got no arm.
I think he did.
Oh, there's a living guy, though.
Wait, I can do this.
Okay.
that person looks maybe alive it's hard to tell honestly i
don't know how you could tell if you played the games it's
fun i've been told by trusted friends that the tv show is
very good oh really oh my gosh a video game adaptation
that's decent sacreble it cannot be It is impossible.
Where'd that guy go?
Wow.
I'm trying to be all sneaky.
I'm trying to be all cool and snipe you.
And you're not, you're denying me my purpose.
Oh, oh.
Get it.
Now why do they explode with the steel tip bolt?
But the incendiary bolt feels like they should be exploding
with that, no?
Is there more for Fallout, New Vegas?
Because Big Iron, Big Key would be timeless.
Bioshock's dream has been magical.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thanks, don't get me!
But with Fallout, what is the proper playing order?
Could you just go into New Vegas?
I mean, Fallout to Vegas.
What is that?
Oh, it's a gift.
Oh, I always wanted a brass tube.
avocado!
Thanks!
I'll take both of those, yes.
Yes.
They're all separate.
Oh, just same universe, but all episodic.
Why is everybody dragging all of a sudden?
Everybody's kind of doing like a little...
Oh, come on.
You had no reason to start blasting.
Fallout New Vegas and Standalone, also the best one since 1
and 2.
Ah, play 1, 2 if you want to try something like a TTRP.
Oh, interesting.
Fallout allows you to benefit from being a cannibal.
I'm seeing benefits.
Or I'm being convinced.
I'm hearing you.
I do have a many a series to get through though Um Oh my
goodness Oh this is not possible Thanks again Um Big one
right now that I'm quite focused on Uh Is uh ace combat I
originally was gonna go like One through You know One
through seven Chipping in for a new Vegas patrolling.
Thank you!
Thank you, KK!
But,
uh...
I think what I might do is do 4, 5, 0, 6 first.
Get caught up for 8.
And then go back and do, like, 1, 2, and 3.
Hmm.
When are you playing MG I guess we...
Someday.
Um...
Three is gonna take a long time.
We'll get there when we get there.
But...
Yeah.
He's Combat Zero, the GO.
I know, I really gotta get caught up on everything.
before.
I don't think I'll I will be caught up before 8.
But I will...
Once I can I will play.
Whoa.
Wow, it's so clean in here.
Holy cow.
Oh, that's scary.
Oh, my gosh.
I almost wasn't able to complete it.
Oh.
Ah!
Stupid.
Not the...
Oh, I'm not trying to use the eye wash station.
It's pretty funny that that's there, though.
Oh, oops, I didn't mean to use the bandages.
No, stop.
Okay, I said I couldn't pick up the proximity mine.
Okay, no.
Too many proximity mines.
Okay.
There wasn't much in here, huh?
Okay, that's fine.
Little Sisters Orphanage.
Did I just hear dogs?
Where am I going?
There's so much cash I can't pick up.
Have a Wii is Disaster Day of Crisis.
Love Child Between Metal Gear and Devil Big Cry.
Oh, yeah?
I...
I have to make sure my Wii is working.
All the Fallout games standalone.
One and two are top-down, crunky RPGs.
Three and onwards are best to style.
I'm meant to play Fallout 3, New Vegas, and my life is
yours.
Okay, we'll start our Fallout journey.
Let me actually put it on my list so that I don't forget.
Let's see.
Uh, fallout.
Yeah.
We could probably do it sooner rather than later.
I don't mind doing too long things at once.
Yeah.
But there's always so many things to do and so little time.
I am headed the right way.
Let's do fire and stuff.
Wait, oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Shoot.
Where are
you?
Where are you?
Yeah, get his butt.
Oh, that's a little sister.
You didn't attack me, right?
No?
Wait, is he mad at me?
He's not mad at me, is he?
No, he's not mad at me.
He doesn't care about me, right?
Who's coughing over there?
Where am I going?
Where have I?
Actually, where am I?
I just kept running.
Oh,
that was my last one, wasn't it?
Did I get it?
I think Big Daddy's not mad at anyone.
I don't remember security being so...
Ouch!
Come on!
Oh, I'm stuck in a wall.
What the hell is this?
Also, leave me alone.
God, I'm just auto-hacking it.
I don't care.
Good lord.
Do you see him dancing?
I can hear him.
Oh.
I guess we're done here.
Oh, okay.
No!
That totally hit you.
Stupid.
I guess we're done here.
I win by doing nothing!
Oh, that's rubble.
That's not a person.
do you think big daddy's still mad at me or you think we're
chill
this is a useless grenade box every time oh we can upgrade
now i almost i pretty i really liked winter blast when i
tried it wondering if i should oh but there's also
incinerate three That might really help.
And also, getting more slots for like these.
Ah, it's hard to say.
I think slots for like combat and stuff are pretty...
Hmm.
Oh, we got the upgrade.
Yes, we did.
freeze plus upgrade wrench is usually a one shot one shot if
i remember correctly really
i think winter blast would be great i'm wondering if i
should switch it out with something else or just buy another
slot because
we can't buy it plus you know we have to
suggestions you're taking i'd love to see more point and
clicking i love point and clicking games definitely more
will happen thank you they die with freeze they don't drop
loot though oh that's true i forgot about that you're right
thank you for the reminder it was pretty powerful
redirecting aggro away from you it's also a nice like yeah
the winter because sometimes fire sometimes my electricity
doesn't affect them hmm also point and clicks are great
because sometimes with like how do i say sometimes with
games like this that involve more you know experience with
you know like with these types of genres and everything like
i'll get i'll get comments from people that are just like
man she is you know obviously some people are just gonna be
like she is so bad and i have to me i'm like sometimes i'm
like wow i've been streaming for almost six years at this
point if i'm still getting comments that i'm like so bad
have i ever have i even like shown any growth you know like
what am i what am i playing these games for if it if it if
i'm just gonna get people that are like you know oh man her
gameplay frustrates me so much frustrates you don't watch
it's okay you know you can watch for the commentary that's
all right too but some people will credit criticize anyone
but i it does it i it doesn't get to me so much but
sometimes you know on days when i'm feeling a little bit
like a little down and i get a comment like that i'll be
like oh man so uh you know beep the haters yeah yeah but it
does it does frustrate me that i'm just like sometimes you
know i know i'm slow i know i'm slow and I have my own kind
of gameplay style and that definitely does not suit
everybody so I totally understand that but sometimes I'm
just like am I just am I just bad at vision game am I bad do
I have bad reflex so but yeah I was thinking about it just
the other day because of like you know yeah
watch you because we like you thank you but you're doing
fine thank you i i know you guys everybody in the chat is
you guys are so often so supportive and you know um i
appreciate it so much and obviously it's one of those
situations where it's like the negative voice is the louder
one but um but yeah wait vent hasn't played mgsv oh no i
have i have I just haven't streamed it on this channel Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah But I have played it, I have I just want to
play it again Eventually Boom
Please believe us over haters Thank you I'll try It doesn't
matter how good or bad you are As long as you have fun I
think that's one thing about me is I am so much more for
having fun Than being really sweaty with a game You know,
like I I am not one to become a master of a of a game you
know I love blue archive but I'm like kind of trash at it
like I don't I don't min-max like I'm just I'm very casual
with my kind of stuff because I'm just like it's fun it's
fun I run around I shooty you know so I'm very not like a
sweaty gamer maybe that's maybe that's my issue because i'm
not so sweaty i i my growth is much slower anyway that's my
tangent i'm gonna get oh oops they call upon their out let's
see what maybe an engine a physical maybe i should just get
the three tonics
what speed runs they can go elsewhere yeah exactly that's
what i always say to myself too
like if there's i can you know i can say every single stream
i can apologize for you know my slowness my awkwardness
everything i could say it every stream and people will still
comment the same stuff you know
physical Let's put in Something And Okay, we're at 350 This
is 160 I could still get another plasmid slot And then Did I
get both sister?
No, I only got one sister here Didn't I?
There was one in the other level that I know I did not get I
also went incinerate 3 though Ah If I get Incinerate 3,
that's already something that I'm replacing.
That is already in my Plasmid Slots arsenal, you know?
Sometimes Minky is stinky, but sometimes you'll activate
TurboGamer Mode 2.
I enjoy both parts.
Thank you.
Slow means your streams are longer.
Me taking a 20-minute tangent, talking about a sandwich I
had the other day or something.
Get on with it, VTuber.
I'm gonna apologize for amazing this.
Thank you, Toriko.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Cyclone trap is very funny.
Is it?
It looks goofy as hell.
Like the little picture.
What?
Physical stuff did I get?
Less damage from electricity.
Oh, the electric flesh.
Which, I don't need to buy this.
I have electric flesh too.
That would be a waste of my money.
Let's talk about the sandwich!
Maybe...
Let me see what combat...
I keep trying to run for some reason.
What combat things do I have?
Like, you know.
Damage research.
I'm frozen field.
Take damage from cold.
Static discharge.
This is the one I have right now.
Oh wait, no, I was I had photographer's eye too You haven't
changed In years, at this point it's on them If they don't
understand Minco's at a lovely Pace, I love listening to
your musings And ramblings while you play, you're the cutest
Thank you, Rodrigo But I do want to change a little bit In
that, I want to get better at game My slowness Is because
I'm cautious And nervous I'm nevers I love that you take
your Mito time.
I'm a loot goblin myself when I play MMOs or GIMS.
So when other people, I've had remarks about being slow and
stuff.
Oh no!
You have your moments of elite too.
Thank you.
I'm wondering if...
I mean, honestly, obviously there's stuff that would be good
here.
Do I not have a human inferno too?
That's so lame.
maybe later increases damage bonuses gain from research
I'm like wondering what I would if I get another slot that's
what I'm trying to figure out I mean these do stack don't
they I could take even less damage which is always a plus
Yeah, that's what I'm thinking.
Getting cautious.
Be getting cautious is good.
Thank you.
Same way at gaming.
I could be slow and check every freaking nook and cat
granny.
Thank you.
Human Inferno 2 on VHS.
We'll have it.
You'll have it at dogs and dinos.
Come to my rental store.
Okay, let's stack that, I think.
Actually, I do want to stack that.
For some reason I keep thinking It was combat
270 I think actually I am going to get the inferno Or
incinerate 3 We will aim For then Winter Blast 3 It might be
tough Double try High skill gamers usually have to stick to
their game genre i think it's more entertaining to watch you
play a variety of games instead oh i think so too i like
playing variety i like playing lots of different stuff is
fun glad you guys agree i like that you look at things there
are things that i haven't noticed in your minto eye that
your minto eyes catch well i feel like probably also like a
game dev would be really appreciative that of two you know
because these games often have so much you know there's
there there is thought to why things are placed right and so
someone probably put something somewhere and was just like
who knows if anyone will ever notice this but might be fine
you know we could do the medical expert 3 that might be good
because it's a plus plus in here Eve link yeah Eve link 2
okay alright um all right let's save with our new with our
new found powers where the heck is the circus our values oh
come on this one is actually unsolvable you're a jerk you're
a jerk.
I'm always get so nervous using these.
There we go, because it makes it go so much faster.
Do you ever need a side gig with absurdly long hours and
horrible pay?
Remember, you could be a game tester.
So true.
Oh wait, now we can actually spend our money though.
for little details.
It's actually one of the things I love about you.
Oh, sweet talk.
Thank you!
Like the unpredictability of someone that isn't a master at
a game.
You know what?
That's so true, though, right?
There is something pretty fun about that, huh?
Yeah!
You guys are right!
I'm unpredictable!
You'll never know what's gonna happen!
Who's speaking?
Who's the apper?
life which has changed humanity to an endless cycle of youth
and faith.
I wish I could get more four-starred kids.
This way?
Oh yeah, yeah.
Okay, I remember now.
Oh, actually, I'm gonna go back and get all my money.
Well, no, it's fine.
We'll get more money.
There was just so much that we left in there, you know.
Wait, I'm saving?
And then I'm hacking?
Uh, no, I didn't- I'm clicking that.
There we go.
Oh, I'm clicking that, yes.
Okay, I'm hacking.
Welcome back, thank you!
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh
gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
You guy.
Yes, yes, yes.
Long guy, long guy, long guy, long guy.
Long guy.
Long.
Oh.
Long guy.
And then.
You guy.
Oh, there's.
I think that was like a box full of chocolates.
Chocolate.
I like it when you panic and scream.
Thank you guys.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, my.
All of the encouragement.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
What is going on?
Uh, wait, what's my inferno?
Oh, that's fine.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Oh, wait.
Actually, I'm taking a picture.
What is it?
Six?
You're on fire!
C!
Action shot.
Beast.
That's right!
Keeps running, coward!
I don't think this guy knows what he's doing.
Oh.
You think Ryan's gonna be
the- Fontaine's Center for the Poor!
Fontaine's the man with the helping hand!
Oh, we need to go in here.
At the bees!
Doesn't it look delicious?
It kind of looks like ectoplasm, actually.
I want to lick it so bad.
It probably tastes so good.
Fontaine's the man with the helping hand.
Made Ryan good and mad when I started playing the charity
angle.
Fontaine's home for the poor.
I don't think I should have gone in there.
Ryan and his precious rapture.
You don't have to build a city to make people worship you.
Just make the jumps believe they're worth the nickel.
I can't wait to kill this guy.
You're curious too?
Where did you guys come from?
Wait a second, can I...
Can I take you out?
If he just runs... wait, if he just runs at me and I plant a
bunch of mines, if I do this correctly...
Because we need the little sister.
Like on a date?
Yes.
I'm ready for dream time, Mr. B.
Wait, I need you to like...
Okay, I think I made a grave error in judgment.
I think I made a grave error in judgment.
Why did I think he would just run?
Oh, I think I'm dead.
I got him.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
No, stop coming at me!
No!
I just want to touch you.
Anyway, um.
No, no, no, no.
Oh.
thank you you're welcome thank you that was scary
oh i see another one in there too holy cow uh i just went
for it smooth as butter i can't believe i killed him so fast
but it was just the fact that it was the fact that guy came
out of freaking nowhere oh this one is not good I was like,
la la la, hey, I'm gonna kill you!
And I'm like, wait, I'm fighting Big Daddy, please.
You don't get that with pro-gaming.
That guy spoke to me too much.
Please understand.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Oh wait, wrong thing.
Yes, okay.
It's so noisy!
What the?
Where is she going to sleep in?
Oh, right there.
I heard another guy, I think.
Oh.
I'm sorry, Father.
I'll do what you say.
Father, we are growing.
Taking potato chips in mansion.
The only people who face capital punishment in rapture.
Now see?
Ah!
Do you think if I get one more?
Sister?
I got both sisters in this level.
But if there was one on the other, in the last one too.
But if I got one more, we might be able to get the winter
blast and the blah blah blah blah.
Another plasmid slot.
In the garden.
Where do these guys come from?
They keep coming from over there.
We are growing.
A little
blah blah yeah exactly.
The napalm that I can't take.
I did say it right.
Whoa where are we going?
Where are we going?
Oh I think he's mad.
Yeah I've been eating everybody's chips.
Like you never been double cross before.
Yeah, but I haven't even been in triple cross.
You don't know.
I know ball I know this like men You me Submarine topside
and more Adam than you can possibly imagine.
I am on my way to point Prometheus One man's vision mankind
salvation I've been triple crossed.
Nothing surprises me anymore.
Is that true?
In the garden, we are growing.
I had to get one last cough in there, huh?
Oh.
Sorry, the game paused.
Uh.
Ouch.
Okay, not snipers.
It's fine.
All right.
Come here and say that to my face, you slimy bastard.
Oh, ow, ow, ow.
She did?
Yep.
Everybody's eating.
I had a feeling she was alive when I saw her.
Is this the director's commentary?
Ouch.
Ouch, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Sorry.
I think I got a hair in my eye.
Give me a couch.
There's gotta be a guard in the veil.
here point Prometheus ah also the game didn't get mad at me
it didn't be like um excuse me you're missing a little oh
wait I guess I thought I was there was another little sister
in this level but it wasn't because it was in that like
previous area I thought we were in like in a totally new
area oh who are you Looking to slug it out?
I'm game.
But I got all the admin to city, pal, and I ain't shy about
using it.
And now, I'm Jake to take her out for a spin.
What is this you wait for?
Go and get this idiot!
Find Fontaine!
Oh.
Me?
Where's the Circus of Aliens?
Can I run up this?
So close.
I should probably, like, have a different gun or something,
maybe.
I'm gonna die here, though.
Because I have no health kits.
I feel like I'm getting soft-locked.
There's a gene bank.
Where can I buy health?
Help me!
Check us out values!
I heard him.
I heard the clown.
Shine!
You let him get away.
Oh.
Was that Fontaine?
He looked different.
Of course.
This will be no problem.
Find a big daddy on search's body.
would suggest you to be finding a dead one search a big
daddy corpse oh you mean that one hello you see the suit
control system that is step one of turning you into one of
those disgusting big daddy the only way to get through that
door Fontaine went through is to have a little one open it
for you and then I will only trust you if you look like,
sound like, and even smell like one of those big, stinking
brutes.
Wait, so...
Let's do breakage chance.
What does that mean?
Automatic tension adjuster greatly reduces the chance of
bolts breaking on impact.
Has that been happening?
Well, um, okay.
I heard the Circus of Values.
I did.
But also...
Um...
Wait, I'm turning into one?
So first time I come here, I'm becoming all mutated and
freaky.
And then...
You're gonna turn me into one of them too?
Where is he?
I wonder if I can get him from here.
I'm trying.
I'm attempting.
I think he is.
I don't know where he is.
Whoa, sweet.
Ryan!
Where's my son?
I'm the father?
No!
Oh!
You too.
Andrew Ryan asks you a simple question.
Are you a man or a slave?
Andrew is dead.
Long live Fontaine until I kill him.
We bred little ones to imprint to certain smells,
pheromones.
But this is not like putting on Esther, she.
You will need three industrial applications for this.
I'm almost dead.
Do you guys see this?
It's kind of crazy.
You will have to gather three pheromones here smell
disgusting just like a big daddy
i heard the circus of values i did the parasite takes three
things free markets free will and free men i just gotta find
it first where do you think you're going you need to become
a big daddy before you are able to draw out the little one
but but uh Ah!
Ignore the lies of Atlas and his paradise.
Maybe it's up here.
I mean at least the- You push me too far, kid.
When you're cold and stiff, I'm gonna go over to my- At
least the thing to revive is right there.
I'm gonna take it apart, piece by piece, and brat by brat.
Brat the brat?
Brat summer?
I'm becoming a dad, yeah.
We found it.
We, I knew it was here.
I found it.
I knew it.
I wasn't crazy.
We got it.
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
Do we got this, though?
Oh, please, game.
Oh.
Uh, wait, uh...
Literally one HP.
I had that so close.
Dang it.
Oh, this one is not soluble.
Look at this!
What the hell is this?
I'm crazy?
Am I?
Don't make me crazy!
I already lost it.
Oh my god.
This one is not winnable either!
Okay, screw it.
Load.
Don't make me crazy.
A crazy from value.
Point Prometheus.
I don't have the cold.
That's the thing.
Oh, it feels so good.
I think we're okay for now.
Now heal?
Now buy one more.
Okay.
Use the...
Here is where you'll be finding the voice box to have sound
like one of those big daddies.
Okay.
Repulsive creatures.
I just gotta...
Kill him?
I have no proximity mind.
I only have frag grenade.
Um...
Let's go.
Let's do it.
Activate my voice changer.
Oops.
Sorry.
Sorry, I had to do it to you like that.
Thank you.
And this is great because we're getting Adam at the same
time.
Yahoo!
Wait, where's my voice box?
Did I get it?
Did I get my voice box?
Or...
I'm ready for you to accept.
Sorry, let me say it real quick.
Let's...
See, yeah, we'll just save over the last one.
Oh, from the room!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
So in here.
Ah!
Oh, oh, DK.
Oh.
Oh, man.
No!
Weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
Leave me alone.
No.
All those med kits I bought.
Yeah, we've used more med kits on this than Big Daddy.
I just saved, though, so I could always do it again.
Not that I want to, but you know.
Can I have one that goes to the right?
Oh, shoot.
Just like that.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
And this way, this way.
And more, more that way.
No, shoot.
No, no!
It's so...
I just don't make me do it again.
I don't think there were enough security drones.
Truly, they're slacking, right?
There should have been at least 15.
All at once.
coming at me.
It's a lot of cigarettes.
Let's not go that way.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Hey.
I'm ready.
I'm a new...
I'm a new ghost.
My cursor, please.
Cursor.
Actually, I don't think this one is...
doable oh no it's not I'm a new ghost let's try again look
he's please oh my gosh no I don't want this one no I want
this one actually be cute a little bit Don't do
it.
Don't do it.
I'm busy.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
This one is craziness.
This one is crazy.
It's too fast.
Oops.
I didn't mean to use that.
I didn't mean to.
I think maybe.
We'll call it here for today.
We're at a new place after.
Oh, wow.
This has to happen every time.
Interesting.
I think we can finish next time.
So screwed.
Is it gonna notice me?
I know you're here.
Holy cow.
Yeah, we'll call it here.
Actually, I'm just gonna run around for a bit.
Oh, oops.
Kill me!
I dare you!
I dare you, I dare you!
So that's the place we need to get into, right?
I'm just looking around right now.
I'm just running.
We're just gonna run and explore for a bit.
But I'm not gonna save or anything.
Oh my god, what's that?
I'm looking
around for a bit, everybody.
Oh yeah.
I think I will call it here, because I'm getting sleepy.
I've been sleepy.
Actually, it's been longer of a stream than I expected I
would go for.
But thank you guys so much.
I'm sorry that I couldn't beat it today.
April, love, oh, there was a guy out there, fools.
Wait, what is this to do the tune of?
Targo, thank you.
For each, wait, something about eye bleach, thank you.
I don't know what that means.
Toriko, thank you.
What is the...
What is the song?
Oh, love fool.
Love me, love me.
Say that you love me.
You need me, need me.
Oh, I'm...
Sleepy, sleepy.
Me and Togo, sleepy.
You're in the end game though?
Realistically, how much How much more of the game do I have?
I'm just curious.
Are Wednesdays still Densetsu meeting days?
I do have a meeting, yeah, in two hours.
Oh, out an hour or two.
Yeah, I see.
I do have a meeting in two hours.
Two hour minimum.
Dang, we're so close, Lan.
That's okay though.
that's okay we can do we uh we can get it in a short little
stream next time yeah
four hours of streamer time okay trust i'll just i'll just
have to i'll just have to talk a little bit more right um i
should have a stream tomorrow um uh full disclosure i will
be traveling Then I'm going to be off for a couple days.
Then I'll have a couple streams.
Then I'll be off for a couple days.
So I won't have a schedule up for the next bit.
I am going on a bit of a vacation for myself.
Finally.
A trip with no work.
But it is a trip nonetheless.
I find myself if I stay at home for a vacation.
Then it will not become a vacation.
I will.
Like, staycations do not exist for me.
I will be working on something.
But, look at that guy running around out there.
Yeah, so, uh...
But there will...
I still have a couple more streams before I go on Shed
Vacation.
I'm watching him in the background.
The mobs in this game are kind of cute.
They're kind of really silly.
But...
Yeah, so...
Um...
You need space away from your workplace.
Just a little bit.
I'm so tired of traveling.
But honestly, the travel has been never ending at this
point.
I'm like, when...
At this point, I need to become a nomad.
Because what's the point of having a home, a maid cafe to go
back to if you are never there?
but it's it's it's exciting things you know it's always like
something that i'm like yeah i get to travel rather i want
to do the thing i do not want to travel for the thing thank
you brandon take care how long will your vacation be uh
about a little less than a week six days um yeah I think
traveling can be the worst part of vacations it's funny
because like I used to love like the you know I used to be
the oh have fun on the travel you don't have to worry like
the destination is not the most important part but then
because I travel so much now I'm like oh but it takes time
and I can't stream when I'm traveling
You're anxious about some travel upcoming too?
Oh no, don't be anxious.
It'll all go well, I promise.
Yeah, yeah.
It'll go well, it'll go well.
Also depends on how you travel.
I'm so tired of doing really long flights, that's all.
Oh, I'm so tired of doing very long flights.
privileged complaint so I don't like complaining about it
and here I am complaining about it again but it's because I
just want to be in my maid cafe streaming for you guys so
that's why it gets me down but it will be for cool things
later so I will do my best yay yay yay yeah yeah yeah
actually I got invited to something pretty cool next month
So, I'm excited to share that with you guys.
Not sure how airports are this week, but be sure to give
yourself enough time.
I think they've been observing my local airport.
I think it's mostly okay.
I'm glad you're getting some good vacation time in Minto.
Have a good time for us, and I wish you the best of luck in
all your travels.
Thank you so much.
Oh, and I will see you guys hopefully tomorrow.
If not, I'll see you guys in a couple of days.
Once I'm back from vacation, we'll finish Bioshock.
We'll punch it in the face.
Thank you for being patient while dealing with all my...
What's the words?
All the struggles of...
The struggles of the game.
All the tech issues that I have with it.
But yay!
Yay, yay, yay.
Of course, Mito.
yeah fontaine deserves as much yeah we're gonna kick that
guy's booty thank you guys as always i appreciate you all so
so much whenever i have everything in the world happening
and all your patience but yeah yeah we we soldiered on
through we got through we managed thank you so much have a
good day have a good night have a good time zone and i will
see you when i see you next tomorrow's stream if i do get to
stream it probably be a little bit later than my usual
stream time um so i will not have a waiting room up until
probably like pretty soonish to the stream i have to like
set up my pc in the hotel
so uh we'll see if i if you know if it works out because
yeah okay
a gorilla stream you know so bye bye thank you everybody
thank you thank you bye bye